Long ago there was a vast multiversal
war countless unique timelines battled
each other for supremacy but then the all-knowing
timekeepers emerged bringing peace by reorganizing
the multiverse into a single timeline now
the timekeepers protect and preserve the
proper flow of time for everyone and everything
stepping off your path created a nexus event
which left unchecked could branch off into madness
leading to another multiversal war
Welcome back everyone, this is going to be my new loki secret
wars video and for king the conqueror explaining
how they set him up in the marvel universe during
episode one his connection to the timekeepers and
the time variants authority so if you're brand new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos i'm doing videos for all the episodes we're
also doing a giveaway for disney plus memberships
all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber and
post all your theories about king the conqueror in
the comments careful for spoilers from everything
that happened during loki episode 1 if you have
not seen the episode yet but a lot of people saw
that scene the history of the tva as narrated by
miss minutes who's played by tara strong she's the
voice of miss minutes if she sounded familiar but
during that they describe a big multiversal war
which essentially is secret wars it also helps
set up doctor strange 2 multiverse of madness
which i'll explain in a separate part of that
big history scene it's a big info dump there's so
many easter eggs just in that one animated little
short movie that they played in the episode
but secret wars refers to a couple major
crossover avengers level events from the comics
so there's the 1980s secret wars which a lot of
you may remember if you're old enough the story
of that is very different from what i'm talking
about i'm talking about the more modern secret
wars during the original 1980s one that was the
beyonder just testing earth's heroes by bringing
a bunch of them to a place called battle world and
just making them fight each other battle royale
style that's also the event where spider-man got
his alien black costume it was called the alien
costume when he first got it later they retconned
that to be the venom symbiote that history video
during episode 1 describes the more modern secret
wars multiverse war event where you have all
these alternate versions of the characters from
the comics being funneled into a single world
after the collapse of the multiverse it remixes
a lot of tropes from the original 1980s secret
wars event but the scope is much bigger because
you're dealing with so many alternate versions of
the characters from different eras in the comics
the difference in the loki series is that sort of
introducing time travel is a much bigger factor
in this multiverse war but also this multiverse
war that they discuss in this history video
sounds a lot like kang war in the comics which is
basically the new avengers team with a different
roster of new characters like you have the falcon
version of captain america spider-man a couple
other different characters versus kang teaming up
with a bunch of alternate versions of himself from
different points in his own timeline and yes this
middle time keeper the second one here does look
very much like kang i mentioned this during my
loki episode 1 video i'll follow up on this in
a second too because this is where we start to
connect things to kang the conqueror in episode
one but a lot of you are confused about the
timeline here like why are they saying secret
wars in the mcu happened in the past the reason
why miss minutes says that it happened in the past
is because the timekeepers themselves didn't come
into existence until the end of time the end of
this current version of the multiverse that we've
been living in during the marvel infinity saga
movie since phase one a lot of you were asking
if the eternals characters were aware of the time
keepers if there's any connection between the
eternals movie and what they were talking about
during loki episode 1 the way they set the tba
up during episode 1 they basically erase people's
minds anytime they come in to fix things in the
past and they didn't come into existence till the
very end of the multiverse so it's unlikely that
the eternals know about what's going on with them
because they were created much closer to the
beginning of the multiverse so you have someone
much later in the timeline manipulating things
it'd be easier for them to erase all knowledge
of them from beings that lived earlier in the
timeline the timekeepers themselves were actually
created by this being called he who remains
who was literally meant to be the last person
left alive inside the multiverse that means the
galactus had died that means the celestials had
died but he creates the time keepers and empowers
them to control the flow of time and then the
time keepers go on to create the time variance
authority and this big citadel at the end of
time and start reorganizing the timeline which
is basically a reference to the sacred timeline
that they talk about in the episode so this really
wondrous place that they're out in the episode the
timekeeper citadel wasn't created till after
the secret wars event happened in the future
so for them and everyone living here in this
little pocket dimension outside of space time
secret wars happened a long time ago in their
past but for the other avengers characters in
present day after avengers end game like doctor
strange spiderman thor this big multiverse war
hasn't happened yet the connection to doctor
strange 2 multiverse of mattis actually
happens later in this little explainer that she's
giving when she starts talking about nexus points
miss minutes says that if enough nexus events
happen and the tva doesn't fix them erase them
with their time reset devices it could create
enough branching timelines alternate realities
leading to a new multiversal war at a different
point in the timeline what did we see that other
version of loki do at the end of the episode who
possibly lady loki early theory about who that is
that they're chasing down she steals their time
reset device preventing them from stopping a new
nexus event so it sounds like she's going around
creating more nexus events and that becomes one
of the connections to doctor strange 2 multiverse
of madness there'll be some more connections to
doctor strange 2 in loki episode 2 as well so i'll
point those out during my full episode 2 video
next week but miss minutes very literally says
too many nexus points could lead to madness in
the multiverse so it sounds like the way they're
setting things up in the mcu with marvel phase 4
on the road to secret wars is that doctor strange
2 multiverse of madness is still meant to be a
really big bookend on this initial multiverse plot
like it'll get crazy with how big the movie is
with the idea that doctor strange and scarlet
witch team up and they prevent the multiverse
from collapsing in this other villain of doctor
strange 2 from completely taking over the main mcu
universe but the movie itself serves as more of a
prequel like an appetizer to a full-blown secret
wars event where you actually do have a bunch
of alternate versions of the characters battling
each other for supremacy battle royale across the
multiverse throwing in the fox x-men characters or
some of them hopefully they'll bring hugh jackman
wolverine back for that but that's the path to
doing the craziest big crossover movie that you
could ever think of like you have a bunch of
alternate versions of iron man you have the thor
core with a bunch of alternate versions of thor
any crazy version of any character that you could
possibly think of the russos also were talking
about doing secret wars movies ever since avengers
infinity war came out a couple years ago they were
just thinking about doing a series of secret wars
movies like you couldn't just do it as one movie
you'd have to do it infinity war and end game
style where you break it into a couple separate
movies but connecting this back to kang the
conqueror so during episode 1 there's a bunch of
easter eggs for him specifically and they changed
some things about the time keepers from the comics
to make the connections to king the conqueror seem
even more obvious so during my episode one video i
talked about how this second time keeper in the
middle here that they keep focusing on his face
he looks very similar to one of kang the conker's
faces in addition to that during the animated
history of the tva video you see what they look
like in full color their faces are blue like
kang's traditional face from the comics but the
middle timekeeper here the one who looks the most
like kang also looks kind of like a depiction of
jonathan magers as comic bookie kang the conqueror
jonathan magers is the actor who they cast to play
kang in ant-man 3 quantomania as the main villain
we don't know exactly where he is in his personal
timeline during the events of that movie because
some versions of kang later in his timeline
are more evil than others and he didn't start
out being evil but this is some fan art of him as
comic book kang does he not look similar to that
second time keeper also some more evidence to back
this up during the episode loki makes fun of the
time keepers calling them space lizards because
in the comics they actually do look reptilian
two of the time keepers here the first one and
the third one do look like they have reptilian
features but the second one in the middle the one
that looks kind of like king the conker looks more
humanoid also in the comics the timekeepers do
make a contract with a future version of kang
to rule over this vast section of the timeline
and keep order that version eventually becomes
a mortise and rules over all of time from a
fortress that exists in an alternate dimension
that looks a lot like the time keeper citadel
and in the comics kang the conquer is also the
longtime love interest of ravana rentslayer
played by gugu M'Batha-raw in the episode
as judge rentslayer she said that the loki series
is an origin story for her character as well
and the way they frame most of her scenes with her
head transposed just in front of this middle kang
looking face as the second timekeeper just seems
like they're foreshadowing her connection to kang
or her eventual connection to him in the future
she was actually asked about this specifically
on kimmel recently about her connection to kang
on the series she had a kind of awkward marvel
sniper answer like marvel will kill me if i talk
about this the vibe you get from her character
in episode one is that she's kind of a goody
two-shoes kind of a teacher's pet character
who just does exactly what she's told to do well
we're doing this we're orchestrating the events
per the timekeeper's wishes because they wish it
so loki sort of points out the ridiculous nature
of this like how do you know with sacred how do
you know what the timekeepers want and at least
at this point in her story she isn't questioning
any of that the sinister nature of any of this
so as mobius and loki go around hunting down
these alternate loki's learning about more
sinister things in the tva sort of pointing out
some of these inconsistencies like mobius seems
like he also kind of understands that what they're
doing is a little bit sinister like burn the place
to the ground here i'll show you to my desk so you
can start there it sounds like ravana rensselaer's
story arc in the series is also discovering some
of these dark truths too like she finds out that
she's possibly been misled this whole time as well
if you haven't read a lot of king the conqueror
stories as well he's also deeply connected to the
fantastic four and obviously we're getting a new
fantastic four movie really soon he started out in
the comics as just a normal human living about a
thousand years in the future he was born nathaniel
richards distant descendant of mr fantastic
reed richards of the fantastic four he became a
scientist fascinated with history and used time
travel technology that had been developed by dr
doom in the past to travel to ancient egypt where
he set himself up as the pharaoh named rama
tut naming apocalypse the mutant as his heir
later he comes back to fight the avengers in
present day with his traditional kang identity
and then eventually he just pops up in the comics
at several points later in his own timeline with
different identities like he becomes the scarlet
centurion version of kang then he becomes immortus
there are a bunch of alternate versions of kang
throughout his timeline there's a teenage version
of kang that becomes iron lad in the young
avengers comics so we'll see which version
he's closest to when we see him in ant-man 3.
my assumption right now is that we'll see him
both as the more human-looking nathaniel richards
and then they'll do a version of his origin story
or it'll play out in flashbacks somehow we'll see
his origin story becoming the full comic book kang
hopefully at the end of that movie just
setting him up as a larger avengers villain
he's just way too powerful and way too big of
a character and way too connected to all these
big different comic book events for them to kill
him off one and done in a single ant-man movie
also fun fact too talking about big twists with
the time variance authority like everything seems
kind of sinister like somebody is being played
here for a fool i know everyone's wondering if
kang is secretly manipulating all of this sacred
timeline business for his own personal goals he
does do that at a certain point in the comics when
he becomes immortus but also there's a really cool
setup moment that i hope that they pay off
later this season when loki is getting his
sentence handed down by judge renslayer he says
you bureaucrats won't dictate how my story ends
most of the mcu characters so far have referred
to loki as the god of mischief but mythologically
loki is also known as the god of stories so we'll
see if they're trying to set up some similar type
of agatha harkness twist with the loki series like
give me akatha all along but make it loki it was
loki all along what greater trick could the god
of mischief pull than having another alternate
version of himself have a hand in manipulating
the tva in the timeline himself tom hiddleston
was also hyping up loki episode 3 in episode four
like this two episode arc as some of the biggest
stuff that they do on the series like he's most
excited for people to see episodes three and four
so it sounds like those will be episodes
where they reveal what's really going on
they kind of paced out the Wandavision series
in a similar way where it was like the last
couple of episodes where you start to find out
what's really going on with agatha harkness and
wanda's chaos magic but if we see any more easter
eggs for king the conqueror or other versions of
loki that might be manipulating things in the tva
i'll point them out in my future episode videos
my full episode 2 video will post wednesday just
like normal but i have a couple other bonus videos
planned before that and if you did spot any big
kang the conquer or secret wars easter eggs during
the episode that i didn't talk about in the video
just write them below in the comments everyone
click here for my full loki episode 1 video and
click here for my loki episode 2 trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!